[Music]
three two one action hey guys welcome
back to off the record or we talk about
whatever we want how have you guys been
whatever we want ever washed that kazoo
before no need no need air washed okay
you know all these instruments just sit
there collecting dust and spit I don't
know better wash this lying the bacteria
dries and dies it doesn't die it dies
well slowly it grows are you sure and it
creates more back to like different
streams of vector
don't ever smell the saxophone yeah
that's don't those strains go to war
with each other and then eventually they
all kill each other and then they all
are dead on the battlefield yep strong
Germany there's one but he's you know
honor where he went
you've the Queen room yeah I have
antibacterial savate saliva like a dog
is that effect yep so during this
quarantine have you just been licking
your hands every time oh my oh no not
Corona cronies new oh okay he's been
doing live shows with me talking about
how he loves to eat [ __ ] oh oh so
you're a giver
so he's cleaning cats a new vine it's a
breakthrough it's a new passion of do
you think I'm a cat person
what do you mean a cat Oh a cat person
he is he loves the kitty now that's been
pretty fun we've been doing live streams
you guys should join maybe enjoy please
down yeah okay fine
we will yeah I didn't know I mean it's
like thanks to this quarantine though
we're figuring out and doing all these
different things that we never had the
time to and just out of it came out of
like necessity to cuz it's like what the
[ __ ] man what am I gonna do
I can't every week we had this or I have
no one really talked to some juices like
lemon
and selling it on the giving lemons
I've been cooking with lemons but
there's a max to that oh well I've been
making me like dishes and stuff we're
adding it in like chicken and yeah he
brought Savitri last time I'm sorry you
missed out on that one but you should
okay I don't know if I'll ever make
ceviche again that [ __ ] takes football
team forever dude it was bombing did you
let let the lime sit anything for two
days I even added oranges so I had a
little sweetness dude you guys Genki
yep along with peeling and cleaning the
shrimp that takes the longest dude
everything else a Dookie in it yep I
don't even it so you get like top it
over with a like whole top yeah so you
grab it you you get like a like a sharp
tool like a like a metal paring knife
chopstick or something you poke it from
the back you rip that [ __ ] you
get the caca you throw it actually you
put it in the sink like that you know
what's cool about a schedule this is
exactly what the cops are doing to you
so I have a buddy that patrols our our
neighborhood and then she was telling me
they've been working which is crazy so
shout out so other cops out there
they've been working
seven-by-twelve so in one week they work
84 hour shifts why do they do more hours
now that they're just when people are
homework they're supposed to be homework
and and or there's still a lot of crime
a lot of crazy [ __ ] going on so they
work seven-by-twelve
just chipping me so they work seven by
12 and then so seven days a week twelve
hour shifts
Oh four hour days and then you know like
cops schedules if something pops off at
the last hour of shift they're extending
it to 1824 Beauty they do but they're
tired as [ __ ] so they work that one week
and then just like us they they go into
quarantine for
two weeks so that way also they're also
doing their own job of Charlie how can
we quarantine our police station so
they'll come and work seven by 12 and
then they say goodbye to everyone for
two weeks everyone goes quarantine and
then during that time that like change
over time those biohazard people come
through the station spray all the phones
down and disinfect the whole place so
even them they're going through all of
it but I texted Jess yesterday I'm like
hey cuz she was the one that designed
like our schedule and I'm like hey shout
outs to you because we because like your
schedule is really similar to what the
cops are doing with the whole incubation
thing so it's cool that you're even
thinking that the same way to make them
that they're doing yeah I mean it's
every two weeks we're meeting up and
doing this so you know how last two
weeks ago we went on the marathon I
didn't even leave the house once that's
how much groceries I had when I was like
[ __ ] I just spend nothing in I'm
saving so much money right now no idea
and I'm not wasting any food I'm eating
every [ __ ] scrap I got [ __ ]
oranges that were going bad and I cut
the mold off and I eat around their
great depression style dude people
finally stocked up on things where you
can go to the grocery store and get
normal stuff again I heard that people
are still there's no toilet paper yeah
my friend is hustling toilet paper dude
what yeah he just texted me he's ready
oh he just texted me the other day try
coming if you literally told me this
he's like and it's so funny the way that
he [ __ ] he got at me about this he
was like hold on hold on [ __ ] words yeah
we're yet where's yet search are you
looking for Jason Chang [ __ ] it's not in
my first got a Costco membership yes and
Nikki's bribed me up and down about oh
you don't really need that much oh we
don't need that much I feel like Nikki
should be here for this
oh well she'll be here tomorrow so I'm
gonna say this today I'm gonna save
tomorrow no no no no he cares about Mary
tomorrow
and I was briefed I bought so much
[ __ ] toilet paper
why couldn't even fit it in my Mini
Cooper to get it at home I had to use
Nikki's car Wow because that's how much
toilet paper I got and guess what wrong
has happened and guess what became the
most scarce commodity toilet paper
thank you I'm the [ __ ] Scarface to
talk never I have all this is Howie this
is how your proposition D goes hey you
need toilet paper I drove all the way to
Montclair Costco today they had they had
a ton of toilet paper
Azusa Azusa though nada I think he got
extra Wow hustle it to us so he should
not even [ __ ] talk to me if you don't
have that Charmin that's true that's the
good good good extra strength yeah yeah
okay I'm fine paper napkins like the
like the square napkin I'm like it's
been sold out for like a good month
flour - yeah
flowers gone sugars gone you know right
before baking for the apocalypse huh you
can't buy yeast by some yeast on Amazon
yeah it's like quadruple the price right
I don't know why it's expensive yes
people are like oh we can't go out and
like buy bread so we're gonna make up
apparel and bread at home I guess yeah
bread was [ __ ] as hell
bread is completely wrecked should we
have these we do what we do yeah I've
cooked like the individual packet we
have one left
yeah I scored some pasta just before all
the [ __ ] went down you did you brought
me here I saw the score cut it off for
Nicky and still got a lot of it there's
still a ton of pasta of the healthy kind
though yeah no one cares it tastes the
same the high in protein ones or a whole
wheat meat the whole wheat that's what
about what I got good taste it's great
especially if you just drench it in like
some tomato sauce you can't taste the
difference have you guys ever tried the
shirt shirataki yeah the power bliss one
yeah the white oh yes bought one
yesterday it's lunch it's weird but then
I'm like if I am trying to lose a little
bit of weight I think I could pretend
that this is real pasta does it fill you
up it actually does this guy's like for
zero calories and zero everything with
no calories yeah
it's like 20 calories for like this big
old fake yeah the maid of shirataki
whatever that if your donkey I know
you're talking about though wait are you
talking about the rubbery one yeah yeah
that we you use in like hotpot and [ __ ]
right no it's like long white noodles
some new [ __ ] it's um we got a yam
Japanese origin but it's crunchy it's
weird you know part it's rubbery when
somebody is at home right now and
they're watching this video and they've
been trying to lose weight
it's like and they heard you say I want
to lose a little bit of weight and
they're like [ __ ] it and there's ordered
a pizza okay it's zero calories
basically well it's it's basically zero
that's like really low you know why it's
all fiber that's why I was full yeah
it's all fiber yeah yeah I love that
[ __ ] I love that [ __ ] too
there's no flavor to it I need to buy
more of it it's rubbery I kind of don't
want to eat it a vertex a person like me
at hams thank you if I don't like tofu
you know what it is it's like um you
know those jell-o cups mmm is that
texture I don't like it's like jello my
job it's Angelica I feel like hard jello
it's weird it's hard it's like hard
jello yeah it's not like je LLO it's
like gelatin like the light she cups
yeah yeah yeah it's like it's that it's
like that jello has horse hooves in it
I'm like eh yo bro I'm now that did it
make it go Oh interesting
it's like eating glue it's just yeah
it's like that I'm like I'm good
I never include I like how you're only
drink things with Molly Portman's
sort of ate what they made out of rock
star energy this one why do they gotta
make it back color out of all the colors
- it's like gasoline
it's like Mountain Dew right if I was a
kid that would be the color I want to
drink really and only that that's like a
liquid highlighter yeah I don't know cuz
I've been around fuels growing up and I
think looking at you all why were you
these run fuels cool it right yeah it
does look like
caca diarrhea it is what it's it's a
nice blend yeah it's a nice blend of
[ __ ] juice looks like a person that
needs to drink some water when I was a
nineties kid because I was a kid during
the 90s I had a bike that was this color
and that was [ __ ] sick dude
there are a lot of things that color
back in the 90s like slime was a big
deal
don't remember surge with surge like
Mountain Dew it was a drink this fan has
news they still have it I was in Denmark
and they call it vault there and it's
still there what surge yet same well
[ __ ] yes
I accidentally tried to order it
recently at a fast food place cuz I was
confusing it with something else I was
like you guys upsurge and they were like
no bro you have Crystal Pepsi recently
he brought a bad idea there oh wow in
the past like 10 months it oh my god
speaking of beverages Bart got a
beverage
today I didn't well we all did we
actually post made it and we all got
Starbucks this morning and it makes it
really really convenient because now
especially when you're supposed to stay
inside sometimes you want to drink
something yummy and you can't go to the
store so you can always postmates it if
you're like me you probably start
thinking about what to eat for dinner
while you're eating lunch I love food do
you like food that's why I love using
post mates they deliver food from every
restaurant I can think of right to my
door name a restaurant Danny's nice post
mates delivers a lot more than just
Danny's burgers or sushi they actually
make my life easier with grocery
delivery and whatever I can think of
delivery to convenience stores clothing
stores you name it I even got batteries
delivered two miles before so no more
trips to the store baby no more
late-night fast food runs I don't even
have to worry about where to grab my
lunch anymore just download post meets
on iOS or Android find her favorites and
get anything you want delivered within
the hour and here's the really cool part
right here so for limited time post
mates is giving our listeners $100 for a
free delivery credit for your first
seven days to start your free deliveries
download the
and use the code off the record that's
the code off the record for $100 of free
delivery credit with no minimum purchase
for your first seven days when you
download the post mates app anything you
need anytime you need a post made it go
check it out link in the description
below post mates we should post much
more alcohol do you think in Amsterdam
they post mates that puss hey you know
they do maybe you know how you Betty
[ __ ] dude you [ __ ] shove it to me I'm
your father Scottie Pippen's thank you
thank you guys you do a great job of
making everybody feel like they had the
best [ __ ] joke on earth and I think
that is the the job of a great
improvising
team Hayman that's what improvisers do
baby the dude just be that I want to
watch this Michael Jordan documentary on
the last dance it's about his last year
on the Chicago Bulls during the [ __ ]
legendary run we're at the at the
beginning of the season Phil Jackson was
told even if you go [ __ ] 90 and or
what 80 something an O which means 82 in
defeated season I will still not bring
you back as the coach of the Chicago
Bulls after winning [ __ ] in five
championships who told him that Jerry
Krause the he was the GM of the Chicago
Bulls and the owner of the Chicago Bulls
hired Jerry Krause and he was like super
loyal to Jerry over my / MJ who [ __ ]
basically delivered the NBA NBA to the
Americas to the world but what Lud why
did he why didn't want to bring back
it's called in go so you look at Jerry
Krause he looks like [ __ ] Danny
DeVito when he was the penguin mmm
and this cat I'm not even kidding this
cat could he could suck Michael Jordan's
dick standing up he easily Mike
inaudible [ __ ] walk through him and
his [ __ ] top of his head will hit his
nuts he's like yeah that's Michael joy
that's MJ's balls yeah and jockey shorts
so yeah that's what's crazy is like they
were willing to blow up the whole
[ __ ] franchise because they weren't
getting the credit MJ was MJ was getting
the credit like being out shine didn't
like things
so if you're an owner and you have a big
ego and you're like wait is my show
that's like at Mike Pence was like
Duncan all loafers every [ __ ]
coronavirus press conference he's like
look what I'm doing man I'm [ __ ]
killing it I I came up with all this
[ __ ] instead what does he do he [ __ ]
puts Trump's dick in his mouth to hold
the whole time like a good number two
should do yeah that's what Scottie
Pippen dead okay
Scottie Pippen his entire job now is
going ESPN he's a Michael Jordan
greatest of all time he's the greatest
ever everyone else is like no it's
LeBron dude right yeah right right well
they tried that [ __ ] and he's like man
[ __ ] you guys basically I actually
watched him say basically that on a
bunch of [ __ ] because that's what
Scottie Pippen's job is now even even
out of NBA his job is to be MJ's number
two still yeah yeah good moil Scottie
there's almost [ __ ] loyal person I
ever live on on the face of the earth
yeah but it's crazy to see what an ego
can do to somebody the fact that you
want a little bit of credit you're
willing to blow up that kind of a
dynasty and they never ever won a
championship after that because I think
it's never about the money to these guys
because they have all the money in the
world so what do they want they want the
fame that they're blogger has or the
love yeah the media attention all that
[ __ ] they should be a Mark Cuban then
yeah they should do it marcus mark human
does a great job as a Dallas Mavericks
owner and he gives a lot of shine to his
team and gives what he also gets credit
to he also get whoa but he pouches for
his players I mean that's the thing too
I think that's the thing where like if
his players are getting technical fouls
or whatever like Mark Cuban the owner
comes out and starts yelling at reps and
he'll he'll purposely get fined just to
make a point in to show that he's got
his players I love it Casey but they
don't exactly [ __ ] win okay they
never outside Mark Cuban championship
okay one can't rush it but I'm talking
about still Jackson he left the Bulls
having won six championships he goes to
the Lakers within what a year and a half
and he wins another championship
immediately there he is the championship
he do
you want he wins 11 swap outdoor Toby
imagine being Jerry Krause and the owner
of the Bulls like Bryan's door and
you're like hey let's get rid of this
Phil Jackson dude let's blow up the
whole team we are such geniuses we could
reboot the whole [ __ ] thing
they've never recovered they never
recovered and then immediately Phil
Jackson wins championship after
championship every champion shooting cat
Lakers it's nuts and that they never
came out and just like let the city of
Chicago like set up a dunk tank let this
is Chicago all take a turn [ __ ]
throwing like a [ __ ] orange at the
dunk tank and like putting them under
and Jerry cross is like get up out of
there and climb back up for the next guy
is a shame they should have had that
that would make Jordans waiting to
baseball yeah that's when you already
came back to me this is when I went to
the Wizards where's that Washington at
the time yeah did they change it I think
so no I think they were just never a
great team ever living in Fairfax
Virginia when the Washington Bullets at
the time we're getting renamed because
it's like offensive and bunch of moms
got sad called bullets soap and [ __ ]
mean I guess but I'm like literally
because of bullets is why I like America
is here but I so so yeah so then I
remember there was the voting there was
a poll at the time there's like go vote
for like go come up with names for the
for the the finalist and [ __ ] so we all
like everybody at my school were all
like trying to come up with names for
the next Washington Bullets and [ __ ] and
they come up with the Wizards I was like
who the [ __ ] actually voted for that I
know one person who's like the wizard
that's a great idea
well now they got the pellet kids or
something yeah pelicans is rough oh why
that tell me about it that could make
her mean I don't even know but it's just
so like maybe they're by a lake no but
you know what you know what happened
Bartlett think think about it Clippers
is probably a better name than Lakers
because these Clippers is something
actin register has been an actual thing
I don't think it's meant for that
clipping all these names suck to be
honest but Bart you know what happened
so they left it to the people to come up
with a name and they cover the Wizards
what radiant was that they probably
exactly what about magic oh man oh man
oh yeah that's sick name Florida oh yeah
that one your lip yeah oh yeah yeah
that's a sick name I mean it sounds just
as lame as Wizards a lot of luck
Utah Jazz oh that's jazz Utah Jazz you
know what I like I like Seattle
SuperSonics I like that super Sonics
remember that song Sean oh Posada Shawn
Kemp CL super Sun so okay but I like I
think that they prop the Hornets is
great Charlotte Hornets dupit dude I
think they probably left it to people
wherever the pelicans are to vote and
they'll game with a [ __ ] pelicans Oh
No just like how they got Joe Biden
instead of Burnie
yup any other ask you don't sports and
are also just waiting for animal
crossing talk come to come back no
[Music]